orca mana joins us live from floyd land  park in the far northwest valley  where a special halloween event is  taking place and orca said you said that  you have a costume it's just not exactly  visible  right that's right sasha happy halloween  to you  i am wearing a costume it might not look  like it but i'm actually the blue power  ranger  just for clarification if anyone was  asking i'm sure no one was but  i felt the need to say that again we're  out here at floyd land park where this  amazing event is going on here you can  see that because of the coronavirus it's  actually a drive-through halloween event  when families can enjoy all the tricks  and treats right from their cars